bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors pour justifier
l'interdiction de la manifestation en
soutien au peuple palestinien à paris
les autorités évoquent un risque de
trouble à l'ordre public le ministre de
l'intérieur dit refuser toute
manifestation antisémite comment vous
interprétez vous cette interdiction bon
écoutez les explications de du ministre
l'intérieur gérald darmanin ne tient pas
legault bien sûr tout le monde d'accord
que on n'a pas à tolérer des
manifestations antisémites qu'il ne
s'agit pas de manifestants ni s'il
s'agit d'une manifestation pour
commémorer la nakba de 1948
celle où les parisiens ont été chassés
de leurs terres qui continue jusqu'à
maintenant qui continuent d'ailleurs ces
derniers temps elle avait une
ramification directement dans le
jérusalem est dans le quartier de cheikh
jarrah les mêmes personnes qui étaient
déplacés en 1948 elle les autorités
italiennes veulent se déplacer ailleurs
pour mettre à leur place
des colons une manifestation donc eux
qui était programmé depuis longtemps ou
commémorer la nakba par des associations
palestiniennes à laquelle donc qu'il y
avait le soutien de plusieurs dizaines
d'associations et de partis politiques
d'organisations françaises et qui va
être interdite ce que gérald darmanin
dit est totalement faux parce que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 2014 mais
il suffit qu'il demande à son ministre
de l'intérieur de l'époque bernard
cazeneuve qui avait même justifié les
manifestations disons que revendiquer
pour les palestiniens les droits en état
et puis que cessent les bombardements à
gaza
c'est quelque chose qui qui est séquence
pied juste qu'ils auraient pu même
justifier toute la france fut dans le
sortent dans la rue mais il avait dit
également une chose qui est extrêmement
importante qui contredit complètement la
thèse de da à gérald darmanin à l'époque
485 manifestations organisées à paris et
partout en france la seule
les seuls qui ont deux
pas des débordements il y avait une qui
était interdite donc justement quel dans
le même endroit à barbès et puis une
autre qui arrivait place de la
république donc rude et rue de la
roquette
il y avait la ligue de défense juive la
ldj qui étaient là bas elle a commencé
la promo des provocations contre les
manifestants il y avait quelques défauts
alors qu'ailleurs taoufik tannique est
ce que cache cette interdiction snif
snif pas tes risques de troubles à
l'ordre public selon vous abbas et la
question c'est clairement la question
des deux poids deux mesures parce que de
plus en plus on constate que toute
solidarité avec la palestine est
considéré comme quelque chose d'illégal
mais par contre assuré la qulité
d'israël ou bien même par exemple avoir
lieu
le groupe la ligue de défense juive qui
assure une manifestation à paris le 25
avril dernier avec leurs drapeaux
ils sont tolérés à ce qu' il faut la
publicité pour le gouvernement d'extrême
droite en israël aucun problème vous
savez en 2001 kp1 lors d'une
manifestation de soutien à israël
il y avait un commissaire de police qui
avait été grièvement blessé et celui qui
l'avait blessé
allez penser juifs extrémistes il a été
exfiltré en israël et le vit des jours
heureux en israël il n'a jamais produit
de son acte en agression contre un
commissaire de police à devant la
justice française
donc en toute logique que il doit
interdire toute manifestation qui tient
par israël a prononcé par le dîner
annuel du crif le dîner annuel du crif
qui est une une tribune de propagande
pour la politique d'extrême droite
israélienne alors les états unis et les
gouvernements européens sont alliés un
gouvernement israélien
il ne condamne que très rarement il faut
le dire les opérations militaires
israéliennes sur les territoires
palestiniens estimant que l'état hébreu
a le droit de se défendre
vous avez encore espoir de pouvoir être
entendue par la communauté
internationale ah oui évidemment je
pense que si tu veux la d'abord une
comparaison avec ce qui se passe dans
les autres capitales occidentales elles
sont toutes là même la même position qui
est désolant vente de celle de la france
ou des états unis
il condamne la résistance palestinienne
mais c'est un vrai lieu sur les crimes
israéliens
mais en france en france il ya une
exception qui est pire que partout
ailleurs en europe même en autriche où
il ya de l'extrême droite qui est au
pouvoir il tolère des manifestations pro
palestiniennes à berlin en allemagne
ils sont vraiment très frileuse sur la
question israélienne il tolère des
manifestations palestiniennes à paris
c'est l'unique l'unique ville capitale
européenne où on autorise pas de
manifestation de solidarité avec le
peuple palestinien c'est à dire que la
question de repêcher la critique toute
critique d'israël est devenue une
politique maintenant de l'état français
et c'est ça qui est inquiétant alors
est-ce qu'on va être entendu nous nous
sommes de plus en plus y compris par
assouté israélienne savait il y avait
les des organisations telles que
b'tselem qui a décrit déjà cette
situation nous vivons actuellement il ya
quelques quelques semaines quelques mois
en parlant d' apartheid comme israël
dans toute la palestine historique dans
le territoire occupé
mais également nous serait même contre
la population arabe
mais il ya aussi une autre ong
internationales human right watch qui a
fait un rapport de plus de 200 pages où
il décrit le système d'apartheid en
israël et il y aussi les menaces qui
pèsent sur les dirigeants israéliens par
la cour pénale internationale qui veut
poursuivre ses dirigeants pour crimes de
guerre voire crimes contre l'humanité
est-ce qu'on ait entendu sur la scène
internationale aussi bien sûr évidemment
les nouveaux ne jouez pas au fait qu
tagne très rapidement pour terminer ce
que vous pensez qu'une paix
est encore possible entre israéliens et
palestiniens et comment est-ce qu'on
peut installer une paix durable selon
vous sur ce territoire là bien sûr
d'ailleurs aux militants comme ça il
faut qu'il y ait une paix entre
palestiniens et israéliens et vous qu'il
qu'ils puissent vivre et qu'ils
cohabitent ensemble que ce soit dans un
seul état ou bien deux états comment on
peut arriver c'est nommer les choses
c'est dire qu'il ya une occupation de
cette occupation doit cesser c'est
simplement tout simplement vous savez
c'est très simple à trouver un solution
il suffit d'appliquer les paramètres qui
sont internationalement reconnus par la
communauté internationale à commencer
par toutes les résolutions de du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies dans la
dernière résolution qu'il a de 2016 qui
parient la colonisation et qu'ils
demandent à israël ne plus construire de
colonies et de rêve de se retirer de ces
colonies donc et demande également à ce
qui est des pressions sur sur le
gouvernement israélien
donc s'il ya des pressions sur le
si il y à une l'application de ses
résolutions de la communauté
internationale on arrivera bien sûr à
résoudre cette question qui vous voyez
malgré toutes les tentatives pour le
marginaliser
elle reste vraiment une question
centrale centrale qui a même de la rue
fut passion
jusqu'ici en france et en europe
sauf que les autres pays européens la
gère une façon intelligente
notre gouvernement français il la gère
la façon la plus abjecte possible
taoufik thani mercier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président d'honneur de l'association
france palestine solidarité merci
beaucoup